par un jour avec johnny guichard
installés à grand coude dans les hauts
de saint joseph il est le seul
producteur de thé en france son
labyrinthe enchanté a pris place sur des
terres où se sont succédé depuis le
début du 20e siècle et culture du thé et
du géranium jean marc collienne et
laurent figo vous avez rencontré ce
grand monsieur du thé oui nous sommes à
grand coude
entouré de thé et ce matin nous vous
emmenons faire la cueillette avec un
petit planteur des os qui craquent mon
panier nous savons par le thé wolverine
a déjà repoussé par coup ci il en est
rama ça tous les jours
johny guichard et son père queuille le
thé je m'entraîne a toujours eu le thé à
grand coude et une histoire qui se mêle
à celle du géranium planté vers 1920 par
les premiers habitants de grand coude
le géranium de la réunion était alors
réputé mondialement
mais dans les années 50 les cours
s'effondrent à grand coude on décide
alors d'arracher le géranium et de
plantes et du thé jusqu'à ce que le
cours du thé s'effondre à son tour et
que l'on décide de replanter du géranium
faut pas oublier qu'en 1955 des
subventions s'appelait auparavant
géraniums appel à nous prendre le thé
c'est un très belle aventure
parce qu'en 1972 le tai chi produit à la
réunion à l'époque dit et noir mais là
cette année la cola fait la roue peine à
ne pas refléter leurs pères blancs de
zaranj homme va comprendre vos dîners
alpha sont ihsan al ne veut pas
peut-être cette histoire de grand coude
dès que grand coup d'un type la taupe et
a dû dans les hauts de saint joseph
tout le monde y outils légaux ont coulé
là les écouter nous la même et je vois
un gros coup de barre va sauter les
babouches à un grand coup c'est
certainement liée à sa géographie et
après c'est vrai que nous parce que nous
lancer de fer se sauvegarder un petit
peu d'histoire goncourt pour le second
coule à travers le théâtre avec son
histoire agricole
l'alléchant classement car voilà bien
[Musique]
quelle sorte de tat blanc alors ça
s'éduque et ben là aujourd'hui c'est
pour la le thé blanc oui exactement
mais après la base qu'on dit et blanc
tva ténois c'est la même plante cinérama
sauter blanc comme ça le thé comme ça
plus tôt il va faire un thé blanc parce
qu'il va être séchées ceni veut faire du
thé vert novateur et fier et du témoin
lui sera fait remonter ce que souvent
les gens répondent ceux des variétés
différentes dont c'est la même variété
koné n'a mais c'est la façon de
travailler des différents
[Musique]
et ce matin johnny guichard nous initie
à la cueillette fine pour produire de
thé blanc alors la sirama il faut
toujours là le tube oh vous terminera
comme ça et appelle le pcot et vie
ramasser des faits qui suit avec
voilà où ça me passer de ma navigation
de votre main comme ça était patent et
en wallonie les tombes
gourgeon et les deux fines donné on
accueilli l'étape suivante maintenant on
va le faire sécher leurs ateliers
pendant que les attirer avec un tout
simplement à une boîte soit pas un
boulon brière et hop et en gros les
prochaines étapes de la production
là c'est dans deux semaines jonathan
semaine soit prêt à écraser en avantage
et on va l'écraser
on va l'écraser constate simplement
et après tout ça latrille et on fait
comme ça voilà
les tiges vont essayer de la le tombé
dessus là on a été tous les jours johny
guichard accueille aussi des groupes de
visiteurs
géraniums fois nous c'est une plantes à
parfum qui sert à faire des huiles
essentielles et ne s'est pas trouvé le
nom de géraniums c'est très simple vous
allez mettre en éveil votre odorat
cellule à claude delaude une fleur c'est
le géranium morose à parce que ça
rapproche de le dehors de l'eau de rose
mais le clou de la visite
c'est ce labyrinthe aménagé dans la
forêt de teillé car si on ne les coupe
pas les théiers peuvent atteindre 15 ou
20 mètres de haut
c'est l'entrée côté il faisait grand
soleil ce matin comme souvent le ciel
s'est couvert en ce début d'après midi
sur les champs de géraniums car denis
richard veut aussi perpétuer cette
tradition du géranium ici à grand coude
[Musique]
johnny et son père vont distiller cet
après midi six ans qu'il de géraniums
johnny tient à coeur de relancer le thé
mais aussi de continuer à gérer n'y en a
que pour notre héros l'ancienneté
surtout de garder notre patrimoine à
l'école de grands pools à travers le
géranium en scène que ce qu'il vaut le
coup quand même déjà assez dur mais
[Musique]
c'est la cuite va durer tout l'après
midi des 600 kg de géraniums johnny et
son père espère extraire un litre
d'huile essentielle de lui-même sa
pensée que vous perpétue la tradition
des anciens c'est vrai que pas dupe
cette tradition là tout à fait mais
c'est vrai que ben en temps de vous
faire la même chose que nos grands
parents que des enceintes y faisait la
même façon médium et d'ailleurs
[Musique]